hello everyone and welcome to the second
day of the semi-finals of defeating
grand prix 2022. all right rihard
rapport versus hikaru nakamura if you've
been following what's uh been happening
yesterday and nakamura won his game
against rapport and also won his game
against dominguez so today dominguez
needs to win the equalize and also
rapper needs to win against nakamura to
equalize he has the white pieces here
and uh he has to try something so how do
you play when you absolutely have to win
uh he goes uh for the there's already a
knight on the board and knight to f3 he
goes for the retti opening and uh well
hopefully we can complicate for as long
as possible without uh
ruining our position and maybe some
chances will uh present themselves so
here hikaru goes for d5 we have g3 uh
the king's indian attack knight to f6
and now bishop to g2 fiance doing the
light square bishop we have e6 castles
and the bishop to e7 so
very very standard stuff here d3 and now
uh hikaru castles we have knight beat to
d2 and not knight to c6 so here's the
setup uh i often uh mention when we have
this set up the the castle king on the
king said very early on the fiance
bishop knights on f3 and d2 and the pawn
on d3 with the possibility of e4 or c4
c4
at some point that this is a setup you
can play against pretty much anything if
you like it i've tried playing it an
online blitz means some three three plus
zero minute games and it's um it's a
pretty good setup
you might enjoy it uh also you don't
have to
uh study all that much theory you know
if you like playing this setup you can
really like play it against uh
most things so here e4
well uh first uh after this knight to c6
move we have d for badaport and already
this is a weird move usually just e4 is
played here but the d4 is kind of
wasting the tempo you played d3 first
time we played d4 and it's only move
seven and hikaru says all right you've
taken uh
away your control over of the e4 square
i'm gonna play knight to e4 and i'm
gonna solidify this with f5
uh we have c3 by rapport uh f5 by hikaru
and now knight the e1 so remaneuvering
uh and trying to
uh trying to make some uh some some
setup here with knights the d3 the other
knight and f3 with some a very very
impressive control over the e5 square so
hikaru strikes in the center with e5 and
we have knight d to f3 uh re-maneuvering
the knights like we said bishop to f6
and now uh e3 and the position is a
known one known one and uh rapport
himself had it uh in a game uh some
three years ago in 2019 where king the
h8 was played but here he car plays b6
and it is now as of movie 11 that we
have a completely new game so let's see
if rapport can create some chances here
knight to d3 uh putting more pressure on
the e5 pawn we are now ready to capture
and hikaru defends it we have rook to e1
and bishop to a6 now hikar is attacking
one of the attackers of the e5 square
that's uh how chess is played we have
bishop to h3 the f5 pawn is undefended
and here hikaru gives up his light
square bishop for the for the very
strong knight so bishop captures on d3
queen captures on d3 and now queen
queen to d7 just defending this f5 pawn
uh rook to d1 now rapper wants the
capture on e5 and this will make the d5
pawn very weak so ahikaru needs to bring
more defenders to the d5 pawn so rook to
d8 and here b4 another move aimed at uh
weakening the e5 square at upper wants
to play b4 b5 chase away the knight and
then you will have more pressure on the
e5 square so hikaru just plays queen to
e6 all right this gets the queen off of
the d file and also you add more uh
protection to the c4 square so if white
had some ideas of playing c4 now it's
not really an option plus uh the rook is
now eyeing that uh well rather x-raying
that queen on d3 so white has to be very
careful uh rapper continues with b5
chasing away the knight now comes knight
to a uh a5 and okay now white will grab
more space with a4 but also hikaru gets
this beautiful c4 square for his knight
so here finally d captures on e5 we have
bishop captures and now knight to d4
this is how rapper makes progress he
also uh has some ideas of getting this
knight to c6 if possible if this knight
ever moves from a5 so queen to h6 you
could also move the queen somewhere else
but this is with tempo the bishop here
is undefended so bishop back to g2 and
only now queen to f6 putting more
pressure here on the knight if the
knight moves also the c3 pawn will fall
and both players are very very low on
the clock so they took this game very
seriously rapport absolutely needs to
win if he wants to have any chances of
reaching the finals uh of defeated grand
prix and he of course wants to do very
well as only a draw uh even even just
the draw would get him to the final so
here rapper plays a4 uh strengthens the
position here and now hikaru just plays
a bishop captures on d4 and this is the
first uh
move where uh
maybe hikaru decides that okay i'm not
playing this game for a win
because he's releasing the tension in
the center and by doing so improving
white's pawn structure uh but it it
really
um
it really simplifies the position and
there's not all that might all that much
for white to do here but if he wanted to
he he could play some like rook to d7 so
you don't have to worry about knight c6
going after the rook next you can put
your knight to the c4 and this would be
very nice so black white does have the
bishop pair but look at the knight on c4
and e4 those are just um uh incredible
pieces but okay yeah hikaru only needs a
draw he played bishop captures on v4 we
have c captures rapport improves his
pawn structure now maybe he can use the
semi-open c file to his advantage but
hikaru of course plays c5 right away and
now you have to react to this otherwise
c4 is coming hikaru is getting a pass
pawn so b captures on c6 alpha
queen captures on c6 and now bishop to
d2 putting pressure on the knight here
and also preparing to bring the rooks to
the open c file so knight to c4 hikaru
finally gets his knights to the c4 and
e4 squares and now rook d to c1
so now pinning the knight we have rooked
the c8 hikaru also puts a rook on the on
the open c file and bishop to e1 so
removing the target from d2 and also
adding a defender of the f2 square we
have queen to e6 uh just getting the
queen away from the
from the c6 square and now rook c to b1
uh shifting the the rook to the b file
maybe now uh you will be able to do
something but as long as this knight is
on c4 it is very unlikely so here hikaru
plays a6 and now the the the position is
not just flexible but also very very
strong uh you you have no hopes of
pushing that a5 pawn now if this ever
happens we're just going to play b5 and
there is no way for whites to break
through at any uh uh side of the board
the the queens have completely locked
the king side uh well maybe you can make
some sort of a breakthrough the center
is completely uh blocked but if you try
some sort of a breakthrough on the king
side it's gonna be very bad for the
white king so here rook b3 uh preparing
to double up he car plays rook to c6
just adds another defender to the b6
pawn rook ate the b1 putting more
pressure but it's not really an issue
and here he cover played the absolute
strongest move and that is pawn to g5
and with this move uh he eliminated all
uh chances of white from uh getting any
hopes of winning this game and he was in
fact in this position that rapport and
nakamura agreed to a draw as there is no
no point in the opera continuing this uh
so some people said that okay maybe he
should have continued because if he
agrees to a draw here then he has no
chances of reaching the finals now it's
nakamura
against the winner of the arunian
dominguez match and that is lavon arun
so we will have nakamura versus arunian
in the finals of defeated grand prix not
tomorrow tomorrow is valentine's day so
no grand prix and valentine's only on
day after tomorrow but uh yeah here
there's just no move white can make make
to even try and make progress here so
the b6 uh square uh very nicely defended
by the knight by the queen by the rook
so you're not getting through here if
you play a5 then just b5 there's uh you
know the position is completely locked
uh there's no way to do anything here
capturing only improves the black's um
uh position and if you try something
like queen d1 maybe you can maybe you
can make
some progress on the king side we can
block this queen h6 and now your only
option is basically to play f3 but after
knight moves back to f6 you are not
getting e4 and we are controlling this
square far too many times and there is
there is just absolutely nothing white
can do here so rapper tried some sort of
um
some sort of a
sneaky way of slow playing the opening
to maybe try and confuse hikaru maybe
try and get some sort of a positional
edge uh but it didn't really work out
for him hikaru is the one that got a
better position out of the opening uh
and that that's just it so incredible uh
game uh
uh
the previous one where he car one really
uh
uh really a complicated one and now just
uh you know holding on to a draw here
saying tarapurti if you want to win then
you have to show me something otherwise
i'm off to the finals to face arenan
uh so yeah that's the game really nicely
uh played by hikaru we'll see if he can
continue this uh in the finals against
levon arun or will levon continue his uh
incredible form uh even in the finals
against hikaru uh we'll see what happens
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it like i said now you can play
this setup pretty much against anything
and it's a very nice setup this uh you
know you can remember this with white
try and play it against uh
a lot of things you know even if the the
e4 pawns get exchanged then maybe you
can even free up the c4 square for your
knight maybe you play a4 to prevent
black from playing b5 you put a knight
on c4 and you will be incredibly happy
so it's possible uh especially if you
don't like playing against the french
you can play it against the french it's
a very nice setup uh but yeah i hope you
guys enjoyed this i would like to thank
kanji
david bryan david kimura medo and
friends air for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the feeder
grand prix until it finishes we are
going into the finals but remember not
tomorrow tomorrow is valentine's day
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day